there's a new word in the language i
found out last week just a week ago
ultra
maga
you're laughing but i mean
i guess the democrats think that this is
their ticket to
electoral success that this is a big
slam on because mega of course means
make america great again you associate
with that with trump if you hate trump
most of the country hates trump okay
this is going to be a big winner so look
at this tape joe biden said it like
eight times last week ultra
maga republicans is the ultra mega
plan the ultra my mega agenda the ultra
maga agenda let me tell you about this
ultra mag agenda this tax plan the ultra
mag agenda and their ultra mega agenda
they are really selling ultra maga so i
heard about this last week on overtime i
never heard it before i said it to me it
sounded like a condom ultra maggot
and
well
they must have heard me because i got a
call from the people at mar-a-lago
saying we think it's a great idea that
trump have their own condom
uh
ultra megan and they
they they're already making them
apparently and they asked me if i would
do the first ad for it so uh
i said sure if the money's right i'll do
it would you like to hear the ad that i
fulfilled okay
[Applause]
i guess
it's gonna be on our podcast for the
computer
hi i'm bill maher here with a message
from maggie nation attention maganation
you've got the maga flag the bumper
sticker and the hat now introducing
ultra maggot condoms
the made in america condoms that will
rig your erection
[Applause]
and have you polling well
ultra mega condoms are made of something
terrific
and people are saying
they provide
a big beautiful wall of protection
[Applause]
other condoms don't work because they're
lazy
and they think the government should do
everything for them
but ultra mega condoms are treated with
a petroleum-based lubricant so you'll be
supporting big oil while you drill baby
drill
[Applause]
and they're thin skinned just like you
ultra mega condoms are ribbed to grab
her by the and
and leave her screaming in english only
[Applause]
ultra maggot condoms come in four sizes
extra large large medium and don jr
[Applause]
try ultra mega condoms and make your
dick great again
you